I'm back.
I was on YouTube settings.
Oopsie.
Sorry guys, I was on my YouTube settings.
Let me check how crunchy it was.
I'll check.
Oh my god.
Damn, that's ugly as hell.
I'm sorry.
I was on my...
Yeah, oh my god, that shit was grunt.
That shit is ugly.
Sorry, I was on my YouTube settings.
Well, it wasn't that bad.
No wonder I was lagging too.
Come on!
Was it that bad?
Was it...
I like how I like just...
lost all my viewers just to change it.
Was it really that bad?
How bad?
Come on.
It wasn't that bad, was it?
It was just a bit bad.
now who am i gonna banish from this match all right it was just a bit bad
all right no i was literally i had it on my youtube i had my youtube settings no i just had to have 1440 um x i was streaming it on 1440p instead of 1080 i lowered the bitrate um i lowered the bitrate but i uh i forgot to lower my res I forgot to lower the resolution.
That's why we were, it was like, uh, crunchy.
I just forgot to do the other thing.
Look, this was a gorilla stream, so...
I wasn't meant to, like, have everything figured out on a gorilla stream.
I can basically do...
You'll be a top-notch team to win this one.
I get to fuck up more.
I'm in the snow.
Like the moon, I shine in darkness.
Yeah, it's clear now.
I have an excuse where I can fuck up more on the gorilla stream.
Okay, now I'm not crunchy anymore.
Okay, it wasn't that bad, guys.
Wait, when you stream at 1440p, does it actually lag?
The stream?
Okay, I can put it at 260.
Let's say I can play at 240 frames.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
I don't know why I've been like lagging often though it's weird I'm gonna check my CPU right now I'm getting my CPU replaced this week oh yeah no I was at it like spikes to a hundred randomly it's so weird like my CPU but I'm getting my CPU replaced this week so maybe it'll work It'll be better.
It just randomly spikes.
Oh my god, Ramona!
Thank you for the 10 gifted songs!
Thank you!
Got a siloed back by everybody on the floor.
Yeah, you do.
Yeah, I was trying to...
Trying to fucking make sure he's okay.
I didn't see him.
Oh my god!
I'm sorry!
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, that was my bad.
I missed my one shot.
I missed my shot.
Sorry, I had like a fear when I saw it.
Instead of mag, I feared a captain.
That is much better.
I guess I'll put it on.
Phoenix now.
Okay, I gotta make sure me and the Loki...
I'm pocketing the Loki as much as I could.
Does that hit me?
No, okay.
Oh, I'm trying!
Oh, I'm sorry, Loki, I'm sorry!
Alright.
Yeah, I paid you...
like how much again i paid like uh okay i have my oh i look
i don't think we're gonna guys ever since i got out of 10 uh 1440p guys uh we're losing uh so oh my god it's so hard to maybe my rose bacon
oh my Oh my god, okay.
Let's go!
We did it!
We're all safe!
Yay!
Ah!
Okay, I don't know about that though.
I don't think we needed that.
But that's okay.
You were getting harassed, like I understand.
Honestly.
I understand.
He was honestly getting harassed for so long, like I understand.
Oh my god, why am I lagging so much?
I definitely need to like...
I'm definitely gonna replace my CPU, because it's been happening a lot more.
Where is it?
Cap one, cap one, cap one, cap one.
Hello?
Oh!
Cap one, cap one, cap one!
Cap one, cap one!
Lookie!
I got you!
One brother back.
Oh my god, I don't got you.
I'm sorry.
I thought I did.
I really thought I did.
Oh, thank god.
No, that thing's not up, didn't it?
Oh my god, I'm like super...
I fucked with you so heavy, bro.
You got on the more and you made me not suffer.
I look into it.
It's been happening recently, though.
I have no idea why.
It's been a recent thing.
Okay.
Bye.
We're doing it.
We'll stop when we lose.
This will be the shortest Stop streaming when we lose This is gonna be like and then we're gonna lose this game I'm gonna be funny if we lose on this game.
That would be so silly Are we gonna sack?
Okay, I had to all that we didn't sack enough We didn't sack enough
oh my uh okay i can't i can't use any clones oh wait i'm not loki what am i saying oh he used clones he used clones though i forgot i wasn't playing loki i was like oh my god guys i can't use any clones dk i'm fine oh no he's gonna get us
I do FPGSE.
It's this, man.
I'm so fucking...
I almost had you, bro.
I'm like, why are you so forgetting?
Get that vehicle moving again!
I even restarted my PC too.
I restarted my PC before my stream.
So I have no idea.
It's been, it's just a, it's a recent thing though.
But...
Woo!
No!
I was to your brain!
Maybe I should do put it on 160.
Okay, maybe it's a 240.
Too many attempts.
I don't remember what my CPU is.
I don't remember.
Looky one, looky one, looky one.
Alright.
There we go.
We're okay.
Everything is okay.
Okay.
One more silo.
Layers, windows, cop- yeah, it's a- it's a recent thing.
I have no idea what's causing it.
It's like a recent thing.
Because like, I used to be the- my- I used to never lag for my skinset in the past.
So I'm pretty- it's just something to do with- something either to my PC or like- Okay.
Okay.
all right mac mac mac mac mac mac mac mac mac mac mac please like like please give me a give me a i'm shooting i'm shooting i shot it i shot it i hope i contribute it we can win we can win no we lost bow for six i don't think winning anything.
Okay, I'm not peeking this.
I will heal, but I refuse to peek.
Alright, nice.
Alright, I am not getting ult in time.
Okay, we lose two in a row out in stream.
What?
Why?
You know, if he used that earlier...
Maybe oh my god, oh my god, please.
Hello.
I will play near my team now.
Oh I think I might die unless Unless Unless we stay on point Hello, hello Hello, if we all stay to get there If we all stay
It's okay.
Oh, it's not okay.
It's not okay.
He's dead.
You got one healer.
Keep around.
It's not okay.
Finish one.
Finish that.
I need reload.
It's not okay anymore.
2-2-0.
settings.
Yeah, I don't know why it's been, it's been like this.
It's so weird.
My CPU just like randomly spikes.
It's not like, it's at 100.
It goes from like, uh, like 60 and then it spikes to 100.
So I have no idea why it does that.
Oh, I'm playing with pizza right now.
I haven't lost yet.
Yeah, you were too late.
Yeah, I was playing pizza.
This might be our first loss.
No, I use AMD.
I use AMD.
Because, like, I had two faulty Intel CPUs that both got fried.
You know, like when they had that thing where the tails were frying both my intel cpu fried yeah and i'm pretty sure uh amd there i think my i think my cpu fried i think maybe because i don't know why like um why that happened oh my god goodbye it's like over time i've been that my cnc's been not dying anymore hello if we are looking oh
the one time i stuck close to him if if he healed me i wouldn't have been next to him that's all i'll say if he was next to me i wouldn't have had to if he was he healed me i wouldn't have had to suck next to him because i needed the invalne i needed the invalne because i wasn't getting healed
That's all I'll say.
It wasn't my fault.
I literally got self-sabotage.
Also, why don't we have a fucking Emma player?
This is going to last because we don't have an Emma.
This is the only reason we're losing.
I please!
I'm like, beloved.
Okay, if we lose a second time, I'm calling it because we had a really good win streak going on.
If at least.
No, I was so unlucky.
I literally had, like, two Intel CPUs that fried.
Because, like, they were the default one.
Like, they were the faulty ones.
And, like, it wasn't, like, it over time, it fried.
It fried, literally, like, um...
Like, it fried nearly after, like, a month.
That was how fucked up it was.
Oh, my God.
Please look behind you.
I don't know what else you want me to do!
See, this is why Loki is so hard to play.
You have to be aware of your entire fucking surroundings every time.
I am so...
position I guess not I was on it I literally went back to it did they break it they broke it they broke at the last minute they actually broke it in the last minute that's crazy they broke it at such the perfect time
but yeah the the intel thing only like um like a certain percentage um are faulty and i got i hit it twice i literally had that happen twice oh now we play emma that's great wait who asked for it okay
please please please every time
I got hooked 3 out of 3 That's fucked up it was It was so fucked up Whoever that was Hey Snowflake please and then made me look back
Is it because of the new Nvidia drivers Oh really is it That makes so much more sense I had to upgrade my drivers I had to upgrade my drivers Um for battlefield is it
if i downgrade right now oh my god are you kidding me oh my that's why i've been frame dropping so hard yeah
i mean it could be like we're doing that on like other uh um no no i have nvidia drivers for gpu We're talking about GPU.
Yeah, I had to upgrade my drivers for Battlefield.
Because they won't let me play Battlefield unless I had, like, that specific, like, driver.
And ever since I upgraded it, my Marvel rival, my Marvel rival, like, for me, I've been, my CPU has been jumping to 100 for some reason.
It's so stupid.
Yeah, it is.
It's pretty stupid.
I had to, because I kept my drivers.
I kept my drivers low.
one that uh oh yeah and the secure boot thing too yeah because i was like i've never lagged before so like i'm not actually lagging in terms of like my gameplay but it's my skin suit that's lagging it's pretty annoying also boba sapien think of the hundred bitties thank you thank you i thought you're queuing to the go to mode mode dude match and not till queuing well i wasn't till queuing really i've been i won like one two three four five games in a row which is i had an unlucky game here and i kept getting hooked so that was super unlucky yeah i know the secure boot is fucking ass all right i'll do what if we lose the next game i'm calling it
because like i don't want to lose everything i gained you know
i know i know it was just the early access too made me do so much for just early access and i only played for like two hours i'm at two to three hours i only played two to three hours
leave the casino i got we got cash out before it's too late
used to do 16 hours what happened i think if i wasn't if my skin suit wasn't lagging i'd play longer but i don't want to give you guys like you know a shittier quality stream for too long i mean i still will but like i just don't want to give it to you for too long
it's doing all right because i'm not in game that's why also no stream tomorrow by the way no stream tomorrow oh my god we have two rocket players what are the fucking odds we have no damage rocket oh and he's not wait is that oh yeah of course the rocket player is not in vc yeah i did I turned DLSS.
I don't know why it does not automatically.
Did that, like, it turns itself on automatically.
I did.
See?
DLSS off.
Oh, anti-alias.
Yeah, I turned that.
I turned it off.
Turn that off.
So I have no idea why it's been doing that.
Alright.
Orch.
okay but no damage rocket is a fucking he has he's weak-willed he swaps off rocket when he's losing not a real one trick we didn't ban oh my god i went to blow my nose and we didn't ban
not a real one he's fucking weak-willed as hell you see when you're losing and you're a one trick and you're a supposed one trick you just mute everybody and keep playing yeah you better fucking commit to it yeah
not a real one trick i know because he i see i've had i've played against him and he literally swaps off if they if it's not working that can't even commit
you really want most people no i'm just saying if you're like known as a rocket otp like you're an actual rocket otp if you're gonna role play as rocket raccoon and like swap off rocket when it ain't working for you then you're not real you're not a real one you're weak as fuck you care more about winning than rocket raccoon that's right you have to stop them from securing the missionaries
You care- you don't actually care about Rocket.
See?
Look!
He cares more about winning!
He's on Luna!
He's on fucking Luna!
Weak as the shit.
Weak will.
Weak fucking will.
I swear to God!
Where the fuck is the rocket?
He didn't even start on his rocket.
Change your name now.
Where even was my rocket?
There was no way to position myself in any other way where it would help me.
See, my rocket at least stays on rocket.
He doesn't care.
He doesn't care about winning.
He just wants to play his fucking character.
Oh, it's...
Why is Wufo's on mag?
Is it Wufo's a support player?
Or is this his like...
Or unless he...
You're gonna destroy it?
my that's unlucky oh guys i'm we might lose this too yeah we might lose this as well
oh nice wait we got a kill oh my god wait we won a fight there was not enough to stack i had to use it if like if there were three of us and we didn't have a fucking rocket then i would believe in oh my god our rocket's dead oh my god okay that's unfortunate and i think our okay our mag is this nice we only
no we're not quitting after three oh hey i'm not lagging anymore though wait i'm not lagging nice wait how did i fix it what did i do to fix it do anything i mean i'll see in the fucking spawn
i don't know what i did it just worked goodbye wait why did they or captain america's fucking don't wait no he's back that's the thing sometimes it just fixes i think it's my cpu frying because sometimes or is i my drivers or my cpu frying because like sometimes it just It just fixes itself like the fake trigger stream.
Like, I don't know what's like, what's going on.
Oh,
he has strange up.
I am ready to put on a show.
It doesn't matter, I'm just gonna die.
It doesn't die.
Yeah, I think it's just the drive.
It's drivers and CPU.
No, I- this was like GG's.
All right.
This was a bonus tree- no, I- Please don't kill me.
Yeah, I didn't die.
Our solo tank is- The fact that our solo tank is, um, Captain America.
It's a little- I'm Serene.
We're...
I'm trying my best.
I'm Ashley.
He's popped!
I got popped!
Alright.
I run.
Oh wait, that's ours.
Oh, I got you rocket.
But who's got me?
Oh shit.
He just soloed it.
Okay.
I'm fine with that.
I'm definitely gonna downgrade my drivers then after the stream.
See if that works.
I hear someone behind me.
Why?
Oh shit!
What the fuck is he doing here?
what the fuck oh my okay okay so which piggy is gonna get out of pts one of my four and five and four pigs why did no one turn around and kill the loki including which side you're on literally i was the only one that saw the This is your sign to play it one way.
You know, the swap, bro?
You just want to lose the game.
Either one's won.
I don't think anyone's going to swap, guys.
Oh, hey, we got triple support.
Maybe that works.
Maybe that'll work out.
I have to put it on...
Do I put on Ultra on or Captain America?
Oh, okay.
I guess I'll put it on Ultra.
I don't think we're winning this, though.
I think this is GG's.
As if we lose the next game, I get out of Celestia too.
I think?
I don't even remember actually.
I don't know where I'm at anymore.
Celestia is such a weird Elo right now.
Also, there's a lot of players that, like, fell hard since they deleted stacking.
I've noticed.
What?
How?
Why?
All
right.
Wait, something is behind us?
Like...
Oh, it was the...
Oh, it was It was so fucking strange.
I was like, what's behind us?
I have to put the snowflake on our ultra, apparently.
Like, how...
Wait, he swapped up!
You swapped off now!
You had eight!
Oh, my God.
You actually had 80 years to swap off.
Like...
Why did you swap off during defense?
I don't understand!
How?
How do you swap off now?
I am ready to put on a show.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god.
Oh, he didn't damage boost.
Thank fucking god, he's stupid.
Mag, mag, I'm literally mag.
Oh, thank god, okay.
We did not need to do that, but that's okay.
okay there you go he only plays he's a fake rocket what the fuck where is he
what oh my god oh my god i was not expecting them to touch now they're gonna pour it out now they can pour it out that sucks oh now they don't pour it out oh Oh my god, and they have lamps too.
We don't win these.
We actually don't win these.
That's crazy.
Oh my god, we...
Oh my god, we actually don't win these.
No, we...
No, this is actually a team death.
This is actually a team death.
How did we not kill the Luna?
How did none of us shoot the eye of this?
I hate, like, players that, like, they swap when in the second round.
Because, like, they don't realize this is a counter-swap game.
Guys, it's not like League where you can't swap after you pick a character.
It's not a MOBA, guys.
You can swap whenever you want.
I know it's crazy concept.
someone is countering you you can change your character it's crazy that exists as a concept i know it's such a crazy concept if you think about it that counter swapping is i think
no way counter swap in my counter swapping in my hero shooter say it ain't fucking so
This is late night queues though.
These are late night queues.
Oh, shit.
My bad.
Sorry for looking at you.
This is like the one team that cannot fucking- Iron Fist right now is like actually B tier.
This is like the one team that can't counter fucking Iron Fist- sorry, Iron Fist right now.
It's insane.
We are that one team that seems to be struggling with an iron fist.
How did you let him fucking do that in front of us?
He was healing in front of us.
How did we let that happen?
No, we don't deserve to win.
We absolutely don't deserve to win.
Oh my god, he's just fly.
No I hear the low heat.
He doesn't, like, I don't know, I hear footsteps.
I was like, I don't know, he's clearly invisible.
unreal how like like the iron fist might as well be invisible women like they nerfed invisible women and then they gave it to iron fist and he just exists to be invisible
oh this might be where he dies he has no bubble too
what really you would think okay whatever whatever Let him, I guess.
Okay, sure.
Fucking chuck it at me, I guess.
Kobe, that shit.
You would think it would go towards, I don't know, the cloak?
That's alright.
Yeah, I can actually hear footsteps in this game.
Oh, it does exist.
No, EOM exists, but it's like their own special EOM.
the regular EOMM it's their own manufactured EOMM it exists but it's just their their version since it's their version it's technically not called EOM if you think about it oh now they have group all
right I'll push the cart cart pushing I'll go yippee I'm not gonna say it's winnable because having hope is a mistake.
It's always better to be a doomer.
I don't know if we have anything.
Do we even have anything?
Oh, Art.
Okay.
He did.
Oh, they're gonna grill this 100%.
Yep.
I caught it.
I had a feeling.
I had a feeling that was what's gonna happen.
No, we're not gonna get any support up.
How do you know?
Because he didn't...
Marble Arrivals has the easiest ult tracking in history.
It's weird.
It's like...
We just stacked.
But he stalled it.
Marble Arrivals, ult tracking, is literally every other fight he has all because it's so easy to build all in marvel rivals can we even make yeah our side locks in touch i was gonna say let's not send on guys let's not send on let's whoa yeah let's not send on everybody are you serious that's so unless That's actually so enoughy.
See, that's what stacking does.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, and then people are like, oh man, how do you all track in this game?
It's every other fight.
If they used it in the last two fights, they're gonna get it again.
If you use Luna Old, when the other enemy team has used Luna Old, when you have Luna Old, the other team has Luna Old.
It's just that easy.
I think like all tracking for this game is just Very simple That's why when people are The good all trackers are the one that knows the percentage And be like oh they're gonna get it But to be fair I feel like if you just think That you're gonna get it every other fight You just automatically assume you're gonna get it every other fight You don't really need percentages for it Unless you're like I guess like in a tournament It matters more You're like oh you gotta push them Cause you're like 80% all charged for the salt now Or some shit But like,
I'm not pro.
I'm just a rank player.
I literally play this as a hobby.
I mean, yeah, if they cancel their alt.
If they're at 50%...
If you alt cancel somebody, they get their alt at 50%.
That means they're at 50%.
So they'll get their alt in the next fight.
That's literally it.
You can get 50% of your alt in one fight.
I play at a high level, but I'm just a casual.
Because I stream variety more.
I play this for fun because I enjoy competitive.
Oh, am I lagging again?
Yeah, it's a driver thing, apparently.
At least now I know.
I'll downgrade it.
I'll downgrade it after the stream.
Yay!
Hey, he's one.
Never mind, he's no longer one.
But I will continue clapping.
Oh no, we lost our siloed at a very bad time.
Our siloed dying is very bad.
It's very bad for him to die at this time.
Okay, let's not send none, everyone.
I can't.
I don't think...
Because we have triple support.
Yeah, I was gonna say, the only thing we have is little troll.
I don't think I can bring it all in time.
How the fuck?
Oh yeah, because they're not triple support.
I was gonna say, that's so unlucky.
It just sucks because...
Oh, I'm dead here.
Yep, it's just me dead.
Whoop.
It's because we're on triple support, so we built the store.
Oh, it's unlucky.
I'm not sure.
The current score is...
I'm not going for top 500.
I'm just playing the game.
I'm not actually...
I'm not grinding for anything.
Oh, but with sapient, they give the 150s.
Thank you, thank you.
After the nurse, Phoenix may not have had an explosion.
That's 38 damage.
And now Iron Fist's basic strike does 30.
But at this point, I might as well just go Loki.
Actually, no.
If he's going Ultron, I have to play later.
Or the Snowflake.
Yeah, we're losing this one.
He does less damage than Phoenix of the melee.
Not even factoring flight.
Double animation canceling.
No, Phoenix is.
Phoenix is metal.
It's hard metal and high elo.
Because if you play in high elo and you can coordinate it well.
She's so strong.
she's like one she's basically a stronger hella and phoenix phoenix and torch are phoenix torch and saia are permaband and hi elo um oh yeah i was gonna say uh oh iron fist oh you're saying iron you want iron fist to get buff no he doesn't deserve it he does not deserve no as a support player he does not deserve any buffs i thought you were talking about phoenix sorry i was like wondering why are you saying he for phoenix i was gonna say what i'm gonna say earlier oh yeah um the reason why invisible i found this out recently but the reason why invisible woman was so strong was because she was so buggy that her her alt was apparently accidentally doubled when she ults she's like her all was not supposed to do that much damage during launch so that's why she was so strong and nobody knew until like recently from what i've heard yeah so her all was bugged in a way that it was doing double the healing than it was supposed to and no one knew until that's why she's so weak now because they
fixed the bug yeah her all was doing two times the heals and that's why she's so weak yeah i had a feeling this was ggs yeah no her all always healing two times and what it should be.
And then they fix it.
That's why she doesn't cheat.
She is so weak now.
He cheated by not going.
Exactly!
That's what I'm saying!
Okay.
How about this?
I will lose one more.
Because then, alright.
I'll just end on Celestia.
I'm happy with... I'll do one.
one more loss.
How about that?
There's, yeah, there's no honor in that, exactly.
There's no honor in this, in that victory.
I'm gonna use the bathroom now.
We're back.
Matt, thank you for the hundred biddies.
Thank you.
Silver!
Um, thank you for the hundred biddies.
Medi, thank you.
There's a hundred biddies.
Thank you.
Is Cloak better than uh, what was it?
Is Cloak better than Viz?
Yes.
She is.
She's a lot better because she's, she's meta in certain math.
because you can use it to push.
You can use it to push forward.
Because you can walk forward with the Cloakle in team fights.
So certain maps is actually meta.
For Cloak and Dagger.
Invis sucks right now.
Ramona, thank you for the 10 souls.
Thank you.
What do you think you want to be today?
Like that.
I shine in darkness.
Let's see.
I mean, we could go low-key Cloak and Dagger.
So we can do...
two forward ults.
I feel like, yeah, I feel like I should play Loki, so our cloak and dagger can have the Involve.
Not bad, Torch.
Fuck, Torch.
Torch is actually so broken.
Uh, Bobo Sabian, thank you for the hundred bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
Even if Iron Fist doesn't get a damage buff, then you need to bring back his old Flurry Punch momentum because his whole shit is movement and not, and he barely even gains height from his right click.
It won't make support live harder, makes him so much more fun as a support player i think you don't deserve rights right now slash jk slash slash jk i i'm just joking and we didn't bat anything because i was i'm bra you're i am a biased individual yes i know i agree with that no i if you are a Fellow die player,
I revoke your rights.
I am a very biased individual.
There's no free speech in this lobby.
In this chat, in this chat, there is absolutely zero free speech.
But all I have left so wrong.
Get ready.
Oh my god, I'm almost...
Yeah, thank you for the videos.
Thank you.
Good.
This is not a safe space for dive players.
Don't you have no rights to dive exactly.
This is not a safe space.
You too.
And also rocket players.
I mean, rocket players aren't even real people, so like they don't get, they already don't have rights because they're not even human.
They're a freaking freak of nature.
But.
Nice.
It's fine.
I'm fine.
I'm about to...
There you go.
You're fine.
You're so healthy.
Look at that.
See?
There's that... There's an iron fist right there.
You think that iron fist deserved rights right there?
You think that iron fist deserved having speaking rights?
Oh my god!
How am I racist when you're not?
not even human rocket like it's not even racism when you're not even human and bucket just push forward
no no no there we go there we go see like that you push forward with it um we're supposed to like I don't fucking know we're supposed to like win a fight there but that's fine oh nice that's fine I'm gonna realize it doesn't stack anymore but that's fine it's fine why is our Emma doing over there like okay oh my god I wanted to be hog around but that's fine
Oh, that's unlucky.
Oh, I was going to ult if I wasn't going to die.
I wasn't going to die.
I accept this.
Ah!
The Rokie Rocket situation is crazy.
Oh,
I got...
Oh, technically it's free.
was just giving me free stuff or like i get free currency
so like technically i didn't pay for it anyway load free load
jesus christ i swear to god is i swear to god please please please i'm right here thank you
It's fine.
Like, literally, that's fine.
I think we're fine.
I don't fucking know.
Oh, my god.
Let me try my best.
Please, he is so low.
He's killed as Luna.
He is also so low.
There we go, we got him.
Max Rocky Raccoon!
Max Experience with Doki Bird.
You will never change my mind.
What
the fuck?
Okay.
That's fine.
Yeah, we did it.
We need sensitivity training for Doki.
Look!
I'm okay with all the other animals.
I just have one exception.
For one particular animal.
All the old ones are cool in my book.
No, you are not.
I can't believe what do you mean.
Just...
Jeff is okay.
now I'm okay with Jeff because he's meta now they somehow made Jeff meta in high low it's up they made him meta rocket will never be meta and then like next season I don't know they buff rocket but for now rocket will not will never be meta exactly he's not even a natural raccoon he's not even a natural born raccoon.
It's a fucking lab experiment.
He's a genetic freak.
He gives other raccoons a bat.
Oh, hey, yeah, yeah, I won.
Bees.
And I get rewarded for my raccoon hate.
Look at that.
You take that back.
Thank you for the hundred pennies.
Thank you, thank you.
I get rewarded.
They surrendered.
That's what fucking happened.
Never punished.
Yay.
Don't keep her in.
She's not.
At least saying, guys, Don't Keeper's just kidding.
It's just being hacked right now.
Don't you laugh when she laughs?
Laird Rock and's backstory.
The hate runs that theme.
When I learned his backstory and his friend's dad, I was like, that's right.
You deserve it.
That's right.
Thank you for the 100 videos.
Thank you.
Do keep these.
See, if you're a regular raccoon, this wouldn't have happened.
I'm saying.
Time to role play and celebrate.
Holy shit.
This is what Doom Mesh looks like when I have everything on...
Oh my god.
This looks so ugly.
When I have DLSS up.
Yeah, it's role play time.
Hello.
It's so crunchy in Doom.
Why is it so crunchy here?
That's right.
Dance for me!
That's right!
At least the one thing that's not crunchy is venom twerking.
Is that crazy?
That's right.
You know your place.
Oh shit, I'm just... Please, I'm just sorry for real play.
I'm just real playing.
That's crazy.
He gets partization.
I'm touching the goods.
Yeah.
Damn right I am.
I'm celebrating a win tonight.
I'm here to celebrate my wins.
Oh, you're in any place?
Who am I gonna banish from this match?
There's a Venomator.
I considered this harassment.
Sorry, thank you for the bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
Bulbasafian, thank you for the hundred bitties.
Thank you.
I think you missed my previous.
Let me correct this by donating again.
Oh, I missed.
We deserve equal rights and less all to the cut.
Thank you for the bitties.
Thank you.
Running human torch.
No, that Venom likes it.
He likes a little pain.
That symbiotic is a fucking freak.
Look at him.
He's wearing all black.
Goddamn freak.
Hey, wait.
Yeah, exactly.
That's why he's a tank player.
He is a little freaky.
He's literally...
Yeah, you're right.
He's literally made of liquid latex.
You can't deny that that man's a freak.
Whoa, there.
It's literally liquid latex.
What a...
and he's wearing it in public did i consent to look at that did i it's like when those okay i've seen this before in an actual ma it's like those people that go to the ma with a collar and leash like i didn't consent to see that at a fucking maul i actually saw that in a maul i saw a lady like with a leash holding like holding a leash for their i don't know their collared like yes it was at a fucking mall i literally saw a fucking sub like a dom sub relationship at a mall this is what venom is i did not consent to see this bdm some i did not consent to it and then when he brings this whole gang over with all their venom skins and everything You think I consented to that?
God damn freaks.
I don't think we're winning this.
Oh, wait.
Our sixth player is not even here.
Please don't connect.
Please don't pick anything.
Please don't pick anything so like the Smash DCs.
I don't like all the...
I don't like any of the people in my game.
Please.
All these people are in my game.
I do not wish to see them again.
Except for my duo.
My duo is my exception.
Come on, DC, DC, DC.
This is all we want.
Wait, actually, we're winning.
We're winning with five.
What the fuck?
This is sad.
Never mind.
Come back.
We're winning.
Come back with five.
Your existence don't- No!
We were actually winning!
No, free love for you.
You got what you wanted.
realized we were winning it was the 5% odds that we would be on our favor in the 5 to 5v6 the monkey paw curls
no free win for me 100 150 think of the 150s boba sapien thank you thank you they were an iron fist player revenge at least i wasn't a raccoon Yeah, but my poor boy, Venom.
I can't believe it.
Go back to my roleplay server.
All right.
Who else slaps?
Let's see.
Who else is a slapper?
Does Adam slap?
I mean, he has a cane slap.
All right.
Gladly be the light.
Where are my roleplayers at?
Where's the roleplay room?
It's here.
No!
I had a cane.
I have my pimp cane and everything.
Oh my god, no fucking.
Is that...
Oh my god, cows on the enemy team.
Who do we have?
Oh, I have Delana.
Okay, that's fine.
Alright.
Cal versus Delena.
I have pizza.
Yes, but...
But this is a pro player.
That's different.
One is a pro.
The other is a streamer.
Wait, is it?
Oh, Delena and Gomez aren't playing together anymore.
Oh, they must have been losing together.
That's...
If they broke up, like if the duo broke up, that means they were losing.
Because I was like, wait, weren't they duoed?
Friendship over.
Oh, they were having long queues.
Oh, okay.
That's why.
That makes sense.
Also, Torito, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, cool.
We don't have a support.
players again oh nice oh but we don't have emma oh they ban emma that's cool oh but we don't have mag oh what do you go from loki and then thinking rocket would be the better choice
why would you give me hope in the hopeless world doing that for the armor guys he could be doing it for the armor you don't know that dude this is actually no delena is like was like celestial one today so like he did he apparently wasn't ranking up because he was at land so like he's technically smurfing if you think about it
i'll give it to delena i'm gonna get on the cow bow but that'll be fine the raccoon curse the battle starts in five wait who banned raccoons who abandoned who took off raccoons in my white list in my blacklist which mod did that I banned the word raccoon for our reason there we go oh they were spelling it wrong okay I was gonna say okay I was gonna say how How were they allowed to say that in my chat?
This is not a safe space for them.
I didn't realize they were spelling it wrong.
That makes more sense now.
Because this is absolutely not a safe space for those players.
Alright, nice.
I need to reload.
I gotta reload still.
Again!
Oh my god, Kanshu times!
Oh my god!
How many ups?
Uh...
That's fine.
Yeah, oh they're gonna- I don't- wait, I have freeze.
Wait, I don't.
I don't.
I might die.
Why?
Oh my god, I was not meant to actually Press space.
This is bad.
That was an accident, actually.
Don't worry, you got this, DJ!
DJ Strange!
Oh, we didn't even need Loodle.
Alright, watch him dance and be embarrassing.
That's so embarrassing, Loki.
Oh, he didn't even use it.
Bro, just use it.
You just wasted your Loodle.
You could have, like...
That's a real Doki bird.
Whoa.
no I know I'm trying to type it was no time oh my god he knows me oh my god guys knows me Wow oh my god oh shit You'll be five.
You'll be five.
You'll be so five.
Oh my god, please.
We're still healthy!
We're still so healthy!
How the fuck?
How are we alive?
That guy did nothing to us.
Oh.
Please tell me he has in bone.
Guys, you think he...
I don't think he had Involve.
I...
Guys, he did not.
He did not have Involve, guys.
Who would have thought?
I can't believe it.
He did not.
Maybe not.
I didn't want to use it, but I guess I will.
I am right.
Wow, this would not let us live technically we should not live through this, but that's a oh shit
He jumped so fast he jumped so high I couldn't do anything He jumped so high
I have seen her nerve iron fist is damage and nerve atom speed oh delena's mad he only swaps the squirrel girl when when he angie oh no i should have told him i am tokey bird no
oh no i should have said i was
Oh, that's unfortunate.
No, he only goes I'm the only go squirrel girl if we don't have two tanks.
Guys, I am joking for JK.
Wow!
I cannot block.
I walked right.
I didn't think he saw me, to be fair.
That was my bad.
I didn't think he saw me i don't i don't
oh my god we had two tanks oh my god it's diana i mean cows on tank too so it's like you know we're we're mirroring we're mirroring our pros like it can't be that bad you know what what if i just give
To be fair, it should actually be on our Hella, because I'm like actually trolling right now.
Because we can't kill a fucking Hella, uh, Iron Fist.
There we go.
Hey, I did that.
Oh my gosh, okay.
I think like, our Hella's gonna get the leader, right?
Technically, that wouldn't make sense.
Oh my, that's unlucky.
Oh, hey, he got frozen, too.
All right.
Can we kill, like, one Iron Fist?
I can.
Okay.
You know what?
I still got it.
Look, there we go.
I'll do it.
I'll do all of the job.
I'll do it all.
I guess I'll kill everything.
I...
True DPS.
They TP.
They TP, they TP, they TP.
Can somebody else...
Can...
Okay, I'm backing out now because our Loki is there.
I'm gonna make an example out of this nigga.
What?
Stay on, stay on, stay on.
Please.
please oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god I I did that you're welcome I don't think we're winning this even though I did I made like a play at the entry there i i tried i tried i really did i really did i really did i don't know how much all i could
try i don't know how much more i what else i could do there i really don't know i'm not gonna build my support outs here i don't even oh we're dead we're yeah we're dead we're
I don't I had a feeling that that was not winnable I'm gonna switch things up including which side you're on I'm Luna Snow I shine in darkness the right heroes could make all the difference he said to me never mind
wait keep it this way vote sapient leave the 100 oh 200 bitties thank you thank you we got another mr.
fister on the enemy team uh you missed one of my goes it's my fault for donating mid fight yeah like it was very intense sorry man i i sometimes it's very hard to reach out when i'm getting fisted in the back all right it's fine delena has yet to crash out it's fine He had a mini crash out,
but that doesn't count.
Because he swapped him back.
He swapped him back.
It's fine.
Delayna is back to not crashing out.
This is winnable.
Is he...
No, don't say that.
Don't say that, guys.
Don't say that.
Or he's gonna swap the squirrel girl.
I've seen him done it.
He will.
He can and will crash out.
Four, three, two, one.
okay they're gonna TP to me aren't they yeah I'm a little scared yeah I had a feeling he was gonna do that that's like a strat in like some ranking wait what the fuck oh I thought that was like enemy mag because I was like what the fuck Oh my god,
there's so many things happening on my screen!
Nice.
I have to reload, but I'm doing it.
Alright, it's fine.
It's fine.
We're just- we might be- we may or may not be delaying our loss, but it's okay.
We're having a great time.
We're bonding as- Oh!
Oh man.
My bad.
What the fuck?
How the fuck did he die?
Where's he like just in him?
Technically, oh my god, okay I'm behind my shield
Just hit go Which was my Luna?
I can't oh there she is there she is.
Sorry, I couldn't it's very hard to tell It's very hard to tell when there's 20 people on my screen Okay.
Okay.
It's not okay, but like, I like to lie to myself.
Oh my god, it was so close.
Goodbye.
I knew it wasn't okay.
Oh yeah, I heard Deadlock got a new update.
I don't think we made... Okay.
JK slash JK.
ITP slash JK.
It's okay.
Sometimes it's just not winnable.
Those are these times.
Judge, jury, executioner!
Oh.
Do you think our low-key is gonna live?
Yeah, he did.
He did it.
He lived.
He survived.
Like, a bare minimum.
That's all we wanted.
Oh, he swapped off a...
I just realized he swapped off a Moon Knight.
I think he has a...
Maybe?
I don't know.
We're walking, we're walking?
Mmm...
He could have saved that.
In a perfect world.
He would have...
In a perfect world, he would have kited that too.
But we don't live in a perfect world, sadly.
Back up a little with her Luna.
Sadly, we don't live in a perfect world.
I know, that's the saddest part.
Oh, I'm behind you.
Oh my god, I'm no longer behind.
Oh my god.
Oh!
In a perfect world, this could be winnable.
But sadly, it was not.
Final score.
One, two, two.
There was...
There would be no Iron Fist in a perfect world.
Who was...
And you wanted me to bump...
You wanted you to bump Amphist?
You know...
The alternate cinematic universe of Doki Bird would have won that fight.
But sadly, I am the universe.
I am the cinematic...
I am the alternate universe that doesn't win that.
Never end on a loss.
Okay, we'll do another.
We'll do another.
Can you avoid mag?
Wait, that's my duo!
Oh, I'm doing one more.
And then I'm getting out of there.
Wait a minute.
That's my duo!
Oh, I want to, I'm sorry, Delana, I'm playing with pizza right now, but maybe next time, maybe next time, you can add me if I'm on, and then we can play next time.
Wait, wait, how many times have you lost with Gomez?
You guys aren't playing anymore.
Do you keep queuing for real?
It's okay, it's okay, one more loss and I'm off.
One more.
Oof.
It's okay, that means you're in the easier queues now.
You're in the easier queues.
Surely, don't worry.
Don't worry.
It'll make your EOMM better the more you lose.
And then you'll get, like, a 10 win streak after that.
You have to lose 10 to trigger the positive EOMM.
That's how it works, right?
Yeah, exactly.
You gotta keep losing.
And then you'll get 10-game win streak.
You just haven't balanced it out yet.
yeah isn't that exactly you should don't if you're having a loser streak keep cute keep doom queuing until you trigger the win streak
exactly don't stop a never-ending cycle of pain and then duo queue with someone with high with who's higher ranked than you so when you do lose you lose less we don't care about your friend.
That's how it works.
And then, but you'll gain more when you're winning, because that's what I'm doing right now.
It's okay.
The friend, yeah, it's okay.
Because then, and then they'll be at your, and then they'll lose until they're at your rank.
And then you exchange friends.
And then you repeat.
This is Nepotism.
That is my LG, too.
I'll do one more.
I wasn't supposed to grow stream this long.
Zechra, thank you for that, but he's thinking, thank you.
Yeah, because I perfectly balanced, like, all things should be.
No, they'll just be on their actual accounts.
It's not boosting.
They're on their actual accounts.
And you're still gonna lose, but you're gonna lose less.
It's gaming the system.
They gave us a system for us to game on.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Exactly.
It's all about finding the loopholes.
Systems are meant...
Exactly.
Systems are meant to be broken.
Speaking like a...
Spoken like a true anarchist.
Yeah, it's not boosting.
The person with the high rank loses more.
So that's why you don't lose.
Exactly!
that man knows what's up
oh shit we all want see I told you everybody just bans torch like fuck torch no one likes that guy what do I ban that I don't even know I guess Phoenix just no one else is playing Phoenix
you'll need a top notch team to win this one alright I'll play Luna now give it to Captain America in the end I'm still positive in the end I'm still have a positive positive win rate.
So it doesn't matter if we uh...
It would lose this one.
Oh, no.
We have a cloak and dagger.
And then I'll downgrade my drivers after today.
Why am I yellow?
Why is she yellow?
It's yellow purple.
Because like, I'm yellow.
It's a shitty skin, but like, it was paid for.
You can't change my mind.
Every Luna skin is ugly except for default.
Look.
Be strong together.
It is.
You just like grippers many.
It doesn't fucking matter what you think.
Oh my god.
As long as anybody shows their feet, you're fine with it.
You just don't care what anything else looks like.
But have a...
Okay.
It's fine.
He's gonna swap anyway.
We've all done bad things, Jeannie.
Now's our chance to make up for him.
Wait, I have to get this to Captain America.
See, look at that!
Look, wait, is that the venom skin?
I did not consent to see liquid latex.
Oh, I should- I didn't realize did I have- Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
That sucks.
I was in the cloak bubble, too.
Oh, I wasn't getting healed.
Never mind.
My HP never went up.
I thought I was getting healed.
I can't believe I ever had that thought in my head.
Nice, this is the only way to survive.
I mean, it's a free push, like I'll take that.
Did he drop?
No.
Oh my god, they triple support, though.
Oh, I had to reload!
That's unlucky.
oh no our will fell down that's awkward goodbye cap goodbye
guys i don't think this is winnable anymore oh wait unless unless wait no if i hope never never have hope i need to remember please if we look at each other we can we can both survive we just have to look at each other okay I'll give it to the wolf sometimes I don't know who would have given my slow pick though it's been too long I need someone to like tell me what to do I love will he live oh nice how does our wolf keep jumping up please you have so much more to live for he has so much to live for my man.
I'm dancing!
Yay!
He has venom up.
I'm trying to keep him up.
Please I frozen venom.
Please I did so much.
Please!
Won't somebody look at him?
No, no.
Okay, I guess I'll look at him.
You know, that's fine.
I can look at him.
Oh, my gosh.
I guess, you know, it's fine.
I can beat TPS too, guys.
They never nerfed my damage.
They never nerfed it.
Technically, it takes four supports to equal my damage if you think about it.
I don't think so.
We struggled.
We really did struggle.
That was like a... I did not... I just randomly chucked that.
There you go.
My... No, it's actually crazy.
Mantis's damage is less than Luna damage.
That's what I mean.
Mantis is like... You need three Mantis to do what I do on Luna.
That's like how fucked up it is to play...
To play any other support I think you're a cloak well first right
Please oh my god.
No, I thought cloak well first cloak I thought you would do it first No, they should buff Luna even more You ulted first last time I based it off that system Get that vehicle moving again
Wait, I'm MVP?
Okay, yeah, no, we're not winning this.
MVP.
Thank you.
Why are you such a downer?
Maybe you will win this.
You know, maybe you will.
Um.
Okay.
I don't know.
It's fine.
Is that a widow?
What the fuck?
That's how much they don't- That's how much they believe in them winning.
They swap widow.
That's how much our- The enemy team believes in the- I- I don't know how much I can heal him.
Please.
I- I have to reload.
If you die because I had to reload, I will be so sad.
Goodbye, Mag.
that's fine I still have him I still have my my why can't I have their Wolverine their Wolverine seemed so much better guys oh my god okay hello everyone we're okay bro god get that Oh, we already used our passive.
That's bad.
We already used our passive for the Wolverine.
Oh, he is so big.
Okay, it's fine.
I'm okay.
Oh, wait.
Why are you in this?
Oh, I guess for...
Oh, Wolverine.
Wolverine.
Please?
Yeah!
Slam dunk!
Apparently this is a 5v6 right now.
Their widow is not a person, not like an actual person in their team.
We are struggling against a 5v6.
I do not think the widow has contributed at all.
How did I miss that?
What the fuck?
I should not have missed.
That's fine.
Wait, that's not fine.
That's not fine.
Whoa, that is not fine.
Very not fine.
Oh, yo.
I hope that, uh...
I mean, I'm pushing with you, Emma.
I don't know what else you want from me.
I'm trying my best to be there for you.
Oh, their wolf has no passive, I know.
Where's that coming from?
Nice.
I'm dead.
God, nice.
No, they're going to swap to Widow earlier.
Literally, their Wolverine's doing everything right now.
Their Wolverine's actually carrying.
I'm like swapping between...
That's so cute.
Oh, no!
Oh, that's unlucky.
We don't have Strange.
Yeah, and we're not touching it.
Oh, unless my boy Venom!
Nope, never mind.
No,
that's why I'm like, I knew we were winning it because we're not even winning a 5v6.
I'm Luna Snow.
Like the moon, I shine in darkness.
I had a feeling.
It was in my bone.
When about this state widow?
Oh.
We have blade now.
Because now I don't know anymore.
Wait, no, that's my duo.
Don't worry, I believe in my duo.
Oh.
Don't worry, I believe in myself.
What?
I guess we're full of...
How bad is Blade?
He is like...
E-tier.
Blade is bad.
It's bad, bad.
It's not great.
He's not really...
100% faith in 50% of this dude.
Which one?
But he looks so cool, though, at least, you know.
At least he looks so cool.
Literally, their widow is like cosmetic right now.
We're struggling.
That's like...
Because like their widow...
The widows have a mantis.
That's why.
The only reason why this widow is not effective at all is because this widow has no mantis for the damage boost.
So like...
That's why you don't see widow anymore.
Oh my god.
What fucking...
Oh, I got kicked by the widow.
I was like, what happened to me?
Wait, what?
Where's my...
Wait, did my...
Oh, my God.
I almost got to the health pack.
Wait, I'm MVP again?
Oh, my...
How did she die?
Where did she go?
Oh, they're running triple support.
Triple support is really strong right now.
No, it's been longer than an hour.
I think it's been like two hours.
No, it's just, uh, triple support is incredibly strong.
I'm trying her best, please.
Can we just push up with...
Push up with Invisal?
Please, push up with Invisal?
Can we push up with...
Okay, thank God.
Okay, we did it.
We did it.
We pushed up with Invisal.
We fucking did it, guys.
Oh my god, we fucking did it.
Us against the world
Oh, I didn't want to lose my invis.
I really didn't want to invis, but this is bad because now we don't have a support up for all of these We don't have yeah Oh, that that still hits me.
No, no, no, that's understandable.
That's understandable
Oh, I don't want to be here.
Wait a minute.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
No, I don't think Wolves is giving you DPS, buddy.
He's literally...
He's getting Wolves' death.
And I don't think he's going to give you DPS.
It's called a DPS ego for a reason.
guys he's playing dps to have an ego you think you think he doesn't have an ego he's nearly a dps player
oh my god it's okay we're okay we got a pick guys oh my god we got two picks it's a christmas miracle
um i'm a little concerned Oh, please tell me we have invis.
Thank god.
We lost players, but like we got it.
Oh, we lost the hella?
Okay, I don't know how the hella died.
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
Look at that.
Look, he's doing nothing.
This widow is literally cosmetic.
This widow is...
He's just... What is he doing?
And we're losing.
Oh my god.
I'm so scared.
Please.
Oh my god.
I'm solo healing.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god.
Oh, I thought that thing was gonna run out soon.
Yes.
Wolverine out.
Yep.
Oh my god.
live but no one's touching for it no one's touching for it oh no one can touch for it i swear to you when this game is over the enemy team will avoid that will oh my god that is the first kill i've ever seen that that is actually the first i've seen a kill from the from the It's from the widow.
I've never seen the widow kill anything before.
Please, please don't...
Oh my god!
What was that?
I told you, Invisal is so bad.
It's so dog shit.
Invisal is so bad.
It's so bad.
Two, two, three.
That was the first.
Look at the widow.
Look, she had the least amount of kills compared to her the entire enemy team.
Like, the fact that she has killed nothing on the enemy team compared to everybody else.
That is...
Oh my god, I heard this guy had fucking...
Alright, I'm done.
GG's.
It's fine.
I'm positive today.
Like, less kills than the support.
GG's.
I'm done, though, today.
I had a, it's okay.
I had, like, a positive...
Okay, not here, though.
But we had, it's a positive win rate.
To be fair, minus 17, that's good for me.
See, this is why I queue with someone higher ranked than me.
So I lose less.
that would no 100 that was not this okay that this widow literally got get carried so hard by their wolf like positive enough look we here we won here and then wait yeah and then it's fine but later i just i hit my e-o-m-m you know i at this mark was when um my e-o-m-m was like you've hit this happened this but we were having a yeah there's like all right enough wins for you there is yeah that was really fun i had a fun time doing my guerrilla stream i miss doing uh mavo rabble's guerrilla streams with you guys um we don't do it often because uh i'm always really busy but today i was just i was just really really craving uh i was just really craving Marvel rivals rank and I was like oh I've been playing off stream a lot might as well stream it you know um but no I mean I do regular streams this is more so for guerrilla stuff you know it's more so for like I just feel like streaming today um because Sunday I usually take a day off but I hope you guys enjoyed watching me play my rivals
even though I was like lagging a lot on well I was lagging in-game but my skin suit was lagging but I'm definitely gonna downgrade my drivers and I'm gonna replace my CPU this week um I finally have time to replace it this so I'm going to do that and hope that fixes stuff because it's been really frustrating,
you know, playing FPS games and just having my skin suit lagging.
But I hope you guys still have a lot of watching.
As always, everybody, say hi, Drayette.
I'm around to get that blood flowing instead for me.
Head to bed because you deserve it.
For those who are new here, my name is Doki Bird.
I usually stream on YouTube, but today I felt like playing Rink.
So that's why I boot up my stream on Twitch.
So yeah, check me on YouTube if you liked my content.
And if you want to support me via other means, feel free to check out my merch.
And I have several merch you can get right now.
And follow me on Twitter to know when I'm ever live on Twitch.
Had a great time playing.
And I'm going to see you guys next time, everyone.
No stream tomorrow.
This week is Hollow Knight themed.
So I'll be having a lot of Hollow Knight streams this week.
But yeah, Tempo, you missed it.
I was about to get off.
But anyway, guys.
I'll see you guys later, everyone.
Bye, guys.
rate pizza because he's still streaming and uh you know he was my duo so you know basic etiquette um i'll see you guys later bye